طلب غريب للمعلمات في مدرسه خاصه في
الاردن الطلب اشعل الجدل بسرعه واثاره
مواجهه وانتقادات واسعه
لبصمه مدرسه طلبت من المعلمات وبشكل رسمي
طلبت منهن تنسيق الحمل ليتم الانجاب خلال
العطله الصيفيه التي تستمر لمده ثلاثه
اشهر وزاره التربيه والتعليم الاردنيه
علقت فورا على هذا الطلب
وحسمت الامر بشكل رسمي الطلب مرفوض جمله
وتفصيلا بحسب الوزاره التصرف فردي
الفيديو يعبر ابدا عن سياسه الاردن
[موسيقى]
لماذا تم رفض هذا الطلب رغم انها مدارس
خاصه ولها يعني متطلباتها وعدد مدرسينها
ليش تم رفض هذا الطلب بانه لا والله لا
يجب تنظيم عمليه الحمل والولاده بالنسبه
للمدرسات او المعلمات بالنسبه للتعليم
الذي يطلب من المعلمات تنظيم الحامل بحيث
يكون بحيث تكون الولاده خلال اشهر الصيف
بحجه عدم التاثير على سير العمليه
التعليميه نحن في وزاره التربيه والتعليم
نؤكد على امرا الامر الاول نرفض هذا الامر
رفضا قاطعا جمله وتفصيلا ولا نقبل به وذلك
لانه لا ينسجم مع فلسفه وزاره التربيه
والتعليم ورسالتها ورؤيتها والقيم التي
تنادي بها واهم قيمه هي قيمه الانسانيه
وقيمه الحريه الشخصيه
الامر الثاني هذا التصرف هو تصرف فردي لا
يعبر عن واقع الحال العام لتعامل المدارس
الخاصه مع المعلمين حيث ان العلاقه
ايجابيه وانا كما وصلني من اداره المدرسه
بيان بانها ترفض ايضا هذا الامر واعتبرته
لاغيا اذا في النهايه هو تصرف فردي غير
مقبول لنا في وزاره التربيه والتعليم وغير
مقبول في جميع الاعراف التربويه في جميع
الدول الاستاذ احمد يعني المدرسه تراجعت
عن هذا القرار او هذا الطلب من المعلمات
هذا ما نفهم منك نعم نعم سيدتي ارسلت بيان
تعتذر فيه عن هذا الامر واعتبرت ما جاء في
الكتاب لاغيا وسوف تحقق في الامر لتقف على
حيثيات هذا الامر
[موسيقى]